he's sitting there in the stool in the
patent office in 1905 and writes three
papers that totally transform science
and if you're thinking about being
misunderstood or unappreciated in 1906
he's still a third class Patrick in 1907
he still was it takes until 1909 before
people realized that this notion of the
theory of relativity might be correct
and it might upend all of Newtonian
physics how is it possible
for three of the greatest papers in the
history of science to be written in one
year by this one person is there some
insights wisdoms you draw plus he had a
day job as a patent examiner and there's
really three papers but there's also an
addendum because once you figure out
quantum theory and then you figure out
relativity and your understanding
Maxwell's equations and the speed of
light
uh he does a little addendum that's the
most famous equation in all of physics
which is E equals m c squared so it's a
pretty good year
it partly starts because he's a visual
thinker and I think it was helpful that
he was at the patent office rather than
being the acolyte of uh some professor
at the Academy where he was supposed to
follow the rules and so at the patent
office that doing devices to synchronize
clocks because the Swiss have just gone
on Standard time zones and swiss people
as you know tend to be rather you know
Swiss they care if it strikes the hour
in Basel it should do the same and burn
at the exact answer so you have to send
a light signal between two distant
clocks and he's visualizing what's it
look like to ride alongside a light beam
he says well if you catch up with it if
you go almost as fast it'll look
stationary but Maxwell's equations don't
allow for that and he said he's making
my palm sweat that I was so worried and
so he finally figures out because he's
looking these devices to synchronize
clocks that if you're traveling really
really fast which looks synchronous to
you or synchronous eyes to you is
different than for somebody traveling
really fast in the other direction and
he makes a mental leap that time
that the speed of light's always
constant but time is relative depending
on your state of motion so it was that
type of out of the box thinking those
leaps that made 1905 his miracle year